[Music]
it feels as if the world is moving in a
faster rate than ever everyday
smartphones are getting smarter
AI is becoming more intelligent and our
environment seems to be getting worse
every year
if you were to travel 50 years into the
future what would the world look like
would robots have taken over everything
would we still be living on Earth would
alien life finally be discovered this is
what F and here's what would happen if
you lived 50 years in the future look
down on your phone and think how far
technology has come in the last 10 years
have you ever imagined what tech might
look like in 50 years what about your
family and friends what will happen to
them in 50 years time we might actually
look back and laugh at how we used to
have to hold our phones how primitive
instead our smartphones will either be
worn or implanted in us through contact
lenses imagine being able to have your
GPS embedded in your vision instead of
having to look down at your phone but
although this all sounds nice there will
be problems too if you don't want to
fast forward yourself into the future
because you're worried that your family
might not be around well you can rest
easy knowing that in 50 years the
average life expectancy will be about 80
to 90 years that's over 10 years longer
than it is today since the 1960s our
population percentages have always
looked like a pyramid but 50 years into
the future that pyramid will look more
like a rectangle this means that there
will be an equal percentage of senior
citizens to toddlers this will have a
huge effect on the economy grandma and
grandpa will be retiring much later and
when they do those seniors homes are
going to be packed with more people in
the workforce jobs will be harder to
find just graduate at school expect to
live at home with mom and dad a bit
longer
especially since AI is expected to be
working over 800 million of our former
jobs by 2030 the world's population will
be at an all-time high by this time the
population of Earth will have reached a
staggering nine billion people more
people means more problems there will be
a much higher probability of food
shortages as we try to grow crops to
feed everyone
due to increasing temperatures crops
will be harder to grow as well and with
70% of the world's population living in
cities crowding will lead to more
diseases being spread and being spread
faster as for the environment well that
doesn't look too good either the Amazon
rainforest will continue to be
deforested and in 50 years time half of
it will be gone don't expect it to come
back either increasing climate change
will render it a parched shrub land
higher temperatures will cause the polar
ice caps to melt to less than 50 percent
of what they are today and the Dead Sea
may actually live up to its name as its
water will continue to evaporate
thinking about visiting American cities
like New Orleans Miami and Houston well
sorry but you're out of luck hurricanes
will get a lot worse in the next 50
years and higher water levels will lead
us to abandon the Gulf Coast but don't
worry it's not all bad although the
world may be dying it's not the only
place humans will have to live in the
next 50 years humans will have begun
colonizing Mars private companies will
even be attempting to travel to the
Alpha Centauri system the closest star
system to our solar system while we're
there we'll visit the Proxima Centauri B
planet which has a good chance of
housing alien life if we don't find any
little green men we might decide to
colonize it ourselves so we've talked
about the human race and the environment
but what about you what's gonna happen
with you fifty years into the future
well first off you won't have to go to
the doctor for your annual checkup
you'll have a device where you can scan
yourself for any diseases watch for body
modifications to rise in popularity and
no we're not talking about tattoos or
piercings you'll be able to get things
like cybernetic eyes that will allow you
to see better and to see things that are
invisible to us today like radiation if
you're rich from your Bitcoin investment
blowing up then you can even get
yourself a designer baby these babies
can be completely customized from simply
what they look like to things like their
behavior and intelligence AI will be as
smart as humans they won't have taken
over the world just yet but they'll be
well on their way
ai will constantly be progressing and
intelligence soon being smarter than
humans could ever imagine ourselves
expect them to be working with us while
humans have more advanced roles in our
jobs so are you ready for all the good
and bad that comes with the future if
not that's okay just live in the present
and slowly grow into it over the next
fifty years who knows in the future we
may not even talk about hypothetical
scenarios anymore will there be any
what-ifs or will every idea in the
universe have already gone through a
computer simulation that sounds like a
question for another what-if
[Music]